some reason the world is like the
algorithm is pushing me on Instagram to
move to Texas because all I do is get
these tick tocks on my Ig feed that say
this is what three hundred thousand
dollars can get you in Frisco Texas
that's where I moved to Frisco Texas
so you're living like a god you have
love straight right now
and like I show my wife
I just paid 1.3 million dollars for my
house in Burbank oh my God and it's a
very modest house
I'll be seeing in Frisco Texas bruh and
I'm like
how far is that from Dallas
I'm doing research I'm like what kind of
flight is that to La I'm like man we
might have to go to jack up
I'm married
we're keeping it either way you know
what I'm saying be strapped up out there
no for sure go watch the white greatness
of Luca Duncan in person you know what
I'm saying bro you got a lot now Texas
is man the cost of living is amazing
yes yeah
um
which city in your opinion I know you
haven't been to L.A much but LA or Texas
on the Mexican food
definitely
at least you're honest yeah definitely
La got it with the tacos yeah that
Mexican OT lied to everybody when he
came on and said Texas oh no I don't
know why he did that I mean you got your
select few but LA's is different it's
crazy to watch the Renaissance of Texas
hip-hop and again like
there's been a lot going on in Texas
over the last decade
um there's been like obviously we can't
be ignorant to the fact Travis Scott's
from Houston Megan to Stein from Houston
a guy like yellow busy had a huge hit
record it was from Dallas both three
wrestling post Malone post Malone is
from Dallas the biggest of the biggest
Dallas Texas he's got a Cowboys tattoo
he's from Grand Prairie but definitely
it's Dallas I think his dad worked for
the Cowboys
um but just in terms of like the
camaraderie now and I just feel like
there's just a special energy between
yourself row I feel like that Mexican OT
is having a moment the Dallas H-Town
connection is strong now as to where I
feel like we really only thought about
Houston yeah or you know shout out to
UGK you know what I'm saying from Port
Arthur but uh but what do you what do
you attribute to like the current
you know moment that's happening I
really feel like just like me like
people like me Ro like I said makes no
tea and it's it's a couple other artists
it's just like a breath of fresh air
like because like you said for the for
the longest
Dallas and Houston like it's Texas but
everybody was just kind of doing their
own little thing like Dallas had what
they had going on he used to work for
Houston San Antonio was for San Antonio
everybody was just for theyself and I
feel like people like me that Mexican OT
kind of opened it up to
like we just open you know we just open
it back up like gave people
made people wanna
do music again if they make sense you
guys are unapologetically Texas yeah
yeah so you gotta you got to put on for
the state that's how I found you was uh
like December of last year I was I was
uh me and my kids were
driving a big bear that's doing most
necessary and the Texas all came on yeah
oh my God this voice is crazy yeah and
then from there I just was I did dude I
just dimed in and I was like appreciate
it man how have I never heard of big
extra blood that's crazy but you know
but but you guys are like again you're
unapologetically Texas
record that's on top 100 right now
yeah yeah you got it going crazy right
now well yeah Texas man it's just I
don't know like I feel like Texas and I
always
stuck behind each other but like I said
it's kind of been slipping lately and
it's been isolated yeah yeah that too
and so
with me and them Mexican LT kind of just
yelling
Texas you know just putting on for it's
kind of made everybody want to like
reunite and just unite in general so
like that's like when I got my chain I
call Sauce walking sauce one of the
first people called me like yeah man
you're going crazy so I just feel like
we bringing all that back like I did
something with Mike Dom so boom that's I
believe in San Antonio so it's just
we're just bringing Texas back to one I
feel like Texas going to be the Atlanta
and well my father Memphis right now
because Memphis got it unlocked yeah and
I feel like Texas is gonna we finna I
mean listen everybody loves Texas
already I mean it's a lot of people like
Loki got cribs there
like but this is because of the like
it's the cost of living and then it's
like it's a big Market a lot of people
well a lot of people do know but they
try to keep it hidden but Dallas and
just Texas in general is a huge Market
Dallas and Houston are huge emergencies
especially like if you think of just
media size oh my God and so that's why a
lot of those people
cost of living solid and then you guys
have amazing uh advancing establishments
yeah yeah
I got the BYOB over there
I never even knew but until I went to
Texas but I just put liquor in a water
bottle for the first it was nice it
wasn't the first time but I had to put
liquor in a water bottle after two
o'clock at the club right here out here
yeah oh yeah yeah what no that's trash
but yeah that welcome to Cali or or the
West Coast in general I mean I own a
nightclub in Scottsdale so yeah there's
one's like 155 hits It's liquor pickup
out there too and I believe we couldn't
even control the bottle like they had a
lock on the bottle and whatever ever in
my life had that and I think I spent
like five Millions football there is a
lock but it's crazy you can't pull your
own you can't drink out of it
technically you're not supposed to
yeah I can't read that's crazy it's
crazy man it is wild
um yo I gotta ask you one random
question
on safe house when you kept your running
out of breath in and then you re-hitch
your line was that what happened did you
run out of breath and you were like nah
keep that in so because just let me tell
you my perspective before you answer
because I'm thinking this guy's
overweight yeah
I'm like it's one of the most fire
things I've ever seen an artist do yeah
because you were just going in and then
you almost like kind of got winded and
you like not keep all that in and then
you picked it right back up okay so boom
if you watched the video you can't hear
me breathing them out so the the audio
they got dropped wasn't the the master
mixed the master version
so like you could hear all of that
extra stuff in the back like you can
hear me breathing heavy and all of it
but the YouTube version wouldn't but it
just so happened it went crazy they
loved it so oh it's so good but was that
what happened you read like genuinely I
ran out of breath but it was I meant to
like it was always meant for me the last
fat guy ever seen an artist
I appreciate it
I think he didn't do that bro you know
but out of breath biggie was that big
pun was running out of breath they
didn't keep that dead I was like it's
hard yeah I mean I started off putting
on for the Big Fellas first
putting out for the Big Fellas my CD
then the state I appreciate you for
wearing a shirt I was I was afraid that
if you came here shirtless I was gonna
then
So lately a lot of people I can't go
nowhere without my shirt now like I walk
in place my manager's like all right
come on give it to me what you talking
about give me a shirt they don't want
you in there unless you got your shirt
off it's like your trademark yeah so
Matt's like well if that's what they
want they got to pay for it so now I try
to go everywhere with it straight on and
they're like come on man take it off and
I'm like what you want for have you ever
heard of the comedian Bert Kreischer
okay so he's this white dude he's one of
the biggest comedians in the world
but he does all his stand-up he's a
chubby white dude he has to have a shirt
off it's like his thing everyone screams
like he almost can't do comedy with a
shirt on it's kind of he's kind of I
feel bad you made the right choice to be
like I'm gonna start wearing it because
then you're just always going to be the
naked dude yeah yeah exactly I mean it
was crazy I'm the most comfortable naked
I feel like I was a nudist I was a
nudist in my past life I don't know
about everybody else but in my past life
I was a naked man for sure for sure
and so now I don't know I just I've
always been comfortable like I was a
football player so I'm always yeah been
comfortable just with my body like if I
wanted to right now I can go to the gym
and I look like got them a black Brock
Lesnar you know what I'm saying
yes sir I used to I used to bang on the
floor and drool out of my mouth yeah and
then hop up and yeah I used to do that
got in trouble for it a lot but I used
to do a shirt off I mean you know Stone
Cold the goat is from Texas I just I
didn't like I don't like beer so I never
I never liked it when he did that he
nasty he nasty what do you drink
I just started drinking liquor now that
I'm like a a rapper like I'm out all the
time right so now you're starting to
drink more yeah I drink one step first
bottle gone it's like we five bottles in
now but what are you drinking cause
Amigos yeah that repo is good yeah
that's that's the thing for me it used
to be Hennessy though but we used to
shut down every clip so he had to stop
everyone switched yeah yeah we had a lot
less violent of a drunk if you're awful
exactly I'm fighting or I'm naked I'm
I'm naked both
no it's crazy um